[Musik]
münster eigene optik aber mit der ganzen
schöpfung ab das wäre ein bewusster wenn
man die wunderbare kreatur sämtlich
fantastische geschafft sind wir im wald
wird wisse für freiheit die treppen und
da expertin megabits litern galt immer
asiatische hersteller
sie sollen glauben dass diese verbrechen
uns gehört so wieder abgestellt
wieso setzt sich eine frau aus besten
kreisen freiwillig immer wieder damit
auseinander
wozu menschen im umgang mit tieren feld
sind davon haben sie diese fehlen
wir befinden uns auf einer sogenannten
bären farm in vietnam
hier wird bärengalle abgezapft und
daraus einen wirkstoff für die
traditionelle chinesische medizin zu
gewinnen
[Musik]
tierschützerin katharina bittner ist aus
zürich angereist um ihre freundin die
tierschützerin jill robinson beim kampf
gegen solche bären formen zu
unterstützen
hier siehst du wogegen wir kämpfen
ja ja
unglaublich
eigentlich ist es in vietnam seit 2005
verboten bärengalle abzuzapfen und
trotzdem gibt es weiterhin beerenfarben
wie diese
offiziell sind dass hier nur haustiere
es ist nicht verboten wären zu halten
solange man ihnen keine galler abzapft
aber schauen sie sich um
das sind alles andere als haustiere
wieso sollte jemand so viele beeren
halten wenn er kein geld mit ihnen
verdienen kann
die behörden drücken offenbar beide
augen zu die tierschützerinnen wollen
das gegenteil dass möglichst viele
hinschauen auch in der schweiz als die
city vereinigung 2005 in der stadt
zürich individuell gestaltete teddy
bären aufstellen dies wollte sich bitte
mit einem gallipoli beteiligen erfolglos
in den arbeits briefe bacher ende
letztes jahr das war mir egal ob er in
traffic werde taufstelle da sehen es
werde den ferne asiatische touristen
könnten sich vor den kopf gestoßen
fühlen befürchteten die verantwortlichen
zusammen mit prominenten wie erich die
slim mark rissi und kurt aeschbacher
stellte billigere egalitäre schließlich
trotzdem auf dank bester kontakte auf
dem balkon des hotels storchen direkt an
der limmat
katharina politiker ist ein gutmütiger
mensch aber beim leid von tieren kann
sie unangenehm werden sehr unangenehm
der bernhardiner trete diese vor wenigen
monaten aus einem tierheim in serbien
dessen schließung 30 aktiv voran
tiere liegen ihr am herzen schon immer
größer generic es hin also von meiner
mutter vor der zelle eine schnecke
spazieren fahren im kinderwagen im
garten über den bakken russland wieder
ins bett aber mit ja oder oesterwind und
vier geschwister tito und wenn ich
irgendwie ärger kam ich bin die jüngste
sie dann bin ich zu dünn und hat und
sich brüstet und das ist wunderbar wir
befinden uns in feldbach am zürichsee
unnötiges hauptquartier von 15 jahren
gründete sie eine mail post eine
tierschutzorganisation die hier ihren
sitz hat die gesellschaft sei zwar
offener geworden führt ihr anliegen sagt
büttiker
trotzdem geht das tierleid weiter aber
besser worden
das ist nicht die letzte passiert
[Musik]
seit zehn jahren ist der handel mit
bärengalle in vietnam verboten und doch
müssen diese beiden wir es ihnen sich
nicht mehr mühe geben potenzielle
beweismittel zu verstecken etwa kleine
ampullen die mit bärengalle beschriftet
sind
hier werde keine bärengalle produziert
versichern mutter und tochter treuherzig
und auch das typische antibiotikum das
den bären verabreicht wird um
infektionen zu verhindern habe nichts zu
bedeuten
[Musik]
die tierschützerinnen dürfen sich alles
ansehen
die bären bis sie zu lassen das zu weil
sie wissen dass die gesetze sowieso
nicht durchgesetzt werden
[Musik]
mit hilfe eines lobbyisten wie katharina
britischer parlamentarier gezielt mit
informationen versorgen
der fehlende draht zu
entscheidungsträgern sei nämlich eines
der hauptprobleme des tierschutzes
hier sind die kanäle in der schweiz und
es gibt viel ab stimmig ist die laufe
falsch will zahlt problems natürlich
dass die türkei stehen haben sobald man
immer so blöd mobilisieren damit die
politiker beim 80 plastisch für mehr
tierschutz organisation und die extreme
gut informiert immer so sagen dass ich
der frau bettina l stehen so richtig
durch minuten durchfahren katharina
social media kletterten von haus aus
liberal aber den menschen sei laut rufen
und mit gesetzten ball zu kommen
es gibt das raubtier wie der mensch es
gibt kein egoist wieder matches geht all
die negative es gibt ein positiver ganz
positive sieht es gibt kann hat er so
schöne musik macht und so schöne
literatur macht dann geschüttelt und
maler und alles es der menschheit 27
der ständerat berät ein importverbot für
haifischflossen büttiker und die lobby
ist wollen darauf aufmerksam machen dass
nicht überall drauf steht das haifisch
drin ist
das passt einfach schön aber wenn man
genau ist ist das bornheim und die
schweiz
das ist mutig sei bitter nötig so
pascale bruderer tiere am liegen hätten
leider noch kaum eine lobby persönlichen
empfinden das ist auch von
organisationen geht wo ihr eine
vorherige recht zügig könnt und trainer
für den tierschutz gesetz noch in
lengerich und relativierte spitze ich
habe es können durchaus dramatische
organisationen stimme bekommt das ist
wichtig mit drei stellen die räte
umgestimmt
und trotzdem wird die abstimmung am
nächsten tag verloren gehen für bittere
enttäuschung und ansporn gleichermaßen
steter tropfen höhlt den stein sagt jill
robinson geduld politisches lobbying und
öffentlichkeitsarbeit zwinge die
vietnamesische regierung immer wieder
dazu den farmen zu schließen
die tiere werden dann in die robinsons
bären rettungsstation neue hanoi
gebracht
ich möchte dir jemand ganz besonderen
vorstellen einen schritt katharina
becker hat bereits patenschaften für
zwei bären übernommen einer davon ist
eben fritz und politiker hat schon
hunderttausende von franken gesammelt
für jill robinson diese spenden halfen
in den vergangenen jahren mehr als 500
galli bären einen würdigen lebensabend
zu ermöglichen
[Musik]
bevor die befreiten bären in den park
dürfen werden sie genau untersucht
viele sind nach den jahren in engen
käfigen gesundheitlich schwer
angeschlagenen versicherers frist
keystone eigentlich will dir passt
streifen ja fantastisch weller was das
für aussichtslose hoffnungslose
situation ist dann weiß man jetzt fangt
schönes neues leben der weg in dieses
neue leben führt über ein
hochprofessionelles team aus aller
herren ländern dass sie hier auf dem
neuesten stand der technik liebevoll um
die tiere kümmert
jetzt will eigentlich so investieren sie
in einem dritte welt land so viel geld
in tieren nicht in menschen
wir machen auch sehr viel für menschen
wir haben zum beispiel bereit sie in
sieben ländern ein therapieprogramm
aufgebaut
wir besuchen mit hunden behinderte
senioren und waisenkinder
uns ist bewusst dass menschen auch
wichtig sind
[Musik]
die stadtwohnung der peters nach dem
zürcher bellevue sie dient der optiker
auch aus büro er war lange sie jagen
stefan spielt thermit gruppe heute ist
er selbständiger investor und
unternehmer ehrung sohn max müssen oft
auf katharina verzichten die sich im
laufe der jahre immer stärker für tiere
engagierte sich das irgendwo muss krieg
nichts verhältnisse alles was aber schon
sagen der tierschutz ist schon der
hauptfokus nimmt das engagement für
tiere viel platz so dass ein film platz
ging an engagement heißt beschäftigt
sich damit schienen nun jetzt viel wurde
besetzt halten
eines von boettichers kern engagement
pelze sie will ein importverbot dieses
qual produktes wie sie es nennt
durchsetzen
bisher erfolglos
meine freunde sagen durch unglaublich
tolle mutter die machte bis zum motiv
bewegt bewegen und das finde ich die
summe nicht einfach kritisieren das ist
wieso man hat oder nicht hat und sie hat
das definitiv und die finther super
[Musik]
eigentlich ist katharina politiker
kunsthändlerin mit eigener galerie
direkt an der limmat
in ihrem spezialgebiet den jugendstil
gilt sie als international gefragte
kapazität heute sich spitzenkoch antonio
tajani ein kochbuch
er und andere prominente haben dazu
vegetarische rezepte beigesteuert genuss
sei durchaus möglich ohne dass dafür
tiere sterben müssten so die botschaft
gebürtiger stiftung illustriert von ted
scapa unter die leute bringen will
tierschutz ist heute billiges
haupttätigkeit dafür lobby irrt sie auch
in der gehobenen gesellschaft dort wo
pelze und gänsestopfleber bei vielen
ganz selbstverständlich dazu gehören
sich gar nicht damit auseinandergesetzt
wer sich auseinandersetzt damit dass man
bis muss leisten dass man soziale betrag
muss leiste jeder einzelne fall ist und
jeder so wie er kann und wie er vermag
und wo es das herzschlag der verstand
ihre galerie wird mittlerweile eine
angestellte obwohl die kunst nach wie
vor eine herzensangelegenheit sei da
haben wir mal was als deko französische
wasser collège de france da haben wir
ganz besonders interessant und dalli
dalli lampe mit oleander dekor
das ist ein riese rarität das ist
service für emilia lay
das ist zufall aussieht so hat er seine
karriere anfang eine wohl haben die
galeristin die sich für tiere einsetzt
das finden nicht alle gut es gibt doch
genug menschen denen man ebenfalls
helfen sollte sagen kritiker
das hat man sie ja schon fragen was
machst du wenn die leute die sie das
feuer geht ist die macht gar nicht ich
kann nie erlebt dass eine rein
irgendeiner form engagiert ist oder für
sales oder suizid oder sie ist geld oder
irgendwie für den armen los geht das der
einem das sagt mir immer die die gar
nicht machen
mein gott
oh ja fütterungszeit in der bären
rettungsstation bei hanoi die lokalen
mitarbeiter wollen die tiere fordern in
dem sie die leckereien verstecken
[Musik]
viele bären brauchen jahre um die
traumata aus der zeit in apathie zu
überwinden
[Musik]
über 500 galler bären hat gene robinson
inzwischen gerettet das ist viel
gleichzeitig ist das ein tropfen auf den
heißen stein allein in china wo robinson
ebenfalls tätig ist wird immer noch bei
mehr als 10.000 bärengalle abgezapft
[Musik]
ich habe immer wieder dunkle momente in
denen ich gegen wände trete und weine
das können wohl alle tierschützer
gleichzeitig wissen wir dass wir etwas
sinnvolles tun
glauben sie mir wir werden das geschäft
mit bärengalle beenden
und zwar schon bald auf gut planen berg
in süddeutschland mutiges haben diesen
betrieb mit 60 hektar umschwung gekauft
und daraus einen gnadenhof gemacht
ein ort der balsam für die seele sein
soll
denn tierleid kann menschen krank machen
physisch krank
jedenfalls solche die ein gespür haben
für tiere
solche katharina politiker also ich bin
sehr jung sehr schwer krank worte wir
das erstmal über tierversuche erfahren
haben was da läuft und wie es da läuft
horror pur
es waren bilder wie diese mit denen sich
bücher intensiv zu beschäftigen begann
und die sie nicht verdauen konnte habe
mich aber irgendwie mit der zeit können
uns der krankheit befreien und bin
irgendwann auch wieder gesund worden und
und hat einen kunden also ich muss mich
halt die dem rahmen der mir möglich ist
die sätze regelmäßig kommen besucher
vorbei heute kinder aus einem sos
kinderdorf und behinderte der
institution barbara keller die begegnung
mit tieren hat für viele von ihnen eine
therapeutische wirkung
[Applaus]
hier soll die würde des tieres
unantastbar sein für büttiker eine
voraussetzung für die würde des menschen
unrecht immer für menschenrechte und
menschenwürde und ich möchte einfach mal
prinzipiell sage die würde sie mir
selber dafür verantwortlich und dass ich
mir selber ist und wenn ihr kind
missbrauch und wenn ich dir mis buch das
heißt schwache missbrauch wenn ich all
die menschen schlecht handeln dann
verliere ich meine eignen würde
also ich würde sagen wer pelz treibt
seine würde europa ab
[Musik]
katharina politikers reise nach vietnam
endet in der haltung bei in der bucht
des untertauchen drachens und mit
folgender frage was war schöpfe kraft
vom wüsste dass es anders renzi vom
bösen wie wunderbar die die rieder natur
während und die wunderbare natur hat sie
und die wunderbar und der mensch hat sie
erkenne an dass sie und dann muss man
halt immer wieder neu anfangen und sage
jetzt erst recht
[Musik]
o